What's going on, guys. This is Rob,
and I guess I should have seen this coming when I threw this on the pole.
But this week you guys voted to see a battle between Peter pork,
the spectacular spider ham, and Roger, Rodney rabbit,
better known as captain carrot, captain carrot. I love captain care,
captain carrot, super bunny,
but before we discuss which of these anthropomorphic adversaries will come out
on top,
let's discuss each character's origin and powers starting with spider ham.
So spider ham was created by Larry Hama, Tom DeFalco, and Mark Armstrong,
and first appear to Marvel tales, starring pier Parker,
the spectacular spider ham in 1983. Now,
after that initial one-shot spider ham starred in his own ongoing series
published under Marvel star comics imprint, which was an imprint.
They typically used to publish comics based on licenses that they'd acquired
like alpha Chuck Norris, karate commandos,
which I really need to cover on this channel.
But spider Ham's title was one of a handful of titles featuring original
characters that actually kicked off the star comics line.
No spider ham whose real name is Peter Benjamin porker lives in a reality
designated as earth, 83 11 and Marvel's universe numbering system,
which is inhabited by various anthropomorphic animals that are basically
parodies of popular Marvel heroes and villains such as captain America and Dr.
Doom, which interestingly Peter Parker was originally not a pig,
but was simply a spider named Peter that lived in the basement of a crazy
scientist named Mae porker, who was, as her name implies a pig.
Now may invent an atomic powered hairdryer. And when she tests it out,
she becomes radioactive. And in the ensuing confusion,
she bites Peter turning him into a pig,
but retaining all of his spider abilities,
realizing that he had become something greater than either spider or pig,
he christened himself spider ham.
Now he would continue living with Mae porker who due to her being radiated by
the blow dryer,
believed herself to be Peter's on and who will go on to use his new found
abilities to fight crime as spider ham,
while also working as a photographer for the daily beagle,
a newspaper ran by Jay Jonah Jackal. Now spider ham,
who would actually be brought into the main Marvel continuity with the spider
verse in 2014,
which saw various versions of Spider-Man from across the multi-verse teaming up
to fight a group of villains known as the inheritors,
and would also show up during the secret Wars event in 2015 and most recently
reuniting with five other versions, man,
to form a team known as the web warriors. And of course,
spider ham Rose to even more prominence after his inclusion and the film into
the spider verse, which is the best Spider-Man film to date.
I don't care what anyone says. Now. Agile has powers.
Spider hams are pretty much the same as Spider-Man.
He has super human strength having been shown to lift up to 10 tons and he can
adhere to walls as well as a pre-cognitive spider sense that warns him of any
impending danger. Now, spider ham has also stayed.
It is able to track others by scent and can move his arms fast enough to create
tornadoes. In addition to his superpowers, when he was bitten by Mae Porter,
he was granted her scientific knowledge, which is used in a variety of ways,
but most notably to construct a pair of web shooters,
which produce web strong enough to swing or restrain his enemies. Now,
spider ham has displayed a level of durability that could only be described as
cartoonish because, well, he's basically cartoon character.
He survived being stepped on by a robot weighing 200,000 pounds,
but it does do significant damage to him. But on another occasion,
he was struck by an alternative universe,
Thor reeling a hammer and was only minimally harmed.
So it was hard to get a real sense of how durable he is because he's just been
written so inconsistently and seemingly depends on whatever the pot dictates.
Now going up against spider ham, we have captured and Karen captain carrot.
I love captain carrot, Kevin [inaudible] bunny.
Who's created by Roy Thomas and Scott Shaw.
And first appeared a new team Titans. Number 16 in 1982,
the following the first appearance,
he would appear in an ongoing series from 1982 to 1983,
titled captain carrot and his amazing zoo crew. Now much like spider ham,
captain carrot comes from a world filled with talking anthropomorphic animals
with his home world being designated earth seat within DCS multi-verse prior to
crisis on infinite earths.
But this designation has since been updated to earth 26 and the current
multi-verse captain carrot's real name was originally Roger rabbit,
but it was later changed to Roger Rodney rabbit due to potential confusion with
the film who framed Roger rabbit release in 1988,
Roger rabbit's transformation into captain carrot can be traced back to a day
and metropolis on earth. One when all the citizens began acting like monkeys,
which prompted Superman to go into space and to investigate. Now,
we notice the strange energy emanating from Pluto,
which he believes to be a planet because this was in the eighties and everyone
was an idiot back then and thought Pluto was an actual planet.
But as he flies towards Pluto,
he runs into an energy barrier surrounding the earth. Now,
when he sees a meteor go through the barrier,
he gets the bright idea to use a meteor, to go through the barrier himself,
which results in Superman being taken to earth, sea,
and the meteor shattering into several radioactive fragments. Now,
one of these fragments ends up a radiating,
a carrot being eaten by comic book artist named Roger rabbit.
But upon eating the carrot Roger's physique instantly becomes more muscular and
he develops powers such as acute hearing and the ability to leap grade
distances.
Now Roger decides to become a costumed hero named captain carrot and finds that
several other residents of the city have also been granted powers from being
exposed to the meatier fragments. And with these new allies,
he would form the superhero team known as the zoo crew.
Now captain carrot has taken part in a few stories in the main DC continuity,
usually within the context of crisis events that reset DCS continuity earth sea
was able to survive the crisis on a vendor's due to its destination as an
alternate dimension instead of a parallel earth and captain carrot and a zoo
crew would play a role in final crisis as they were part of the team of heroes
that took on Mandrax. The dark monitor.
Now captain carrot is briefly appeared in the new 52 continuity and the
Multiversity storyline by grant Morrison and during the multiplicity storyline
and the Superman title during DC rebirth back when it was good.
But most recently it was revealed in dark nights, death metal,
multi versus in that earth, 26 was destroyed by the villain Perpetua.
And so captain coats powers are pretty similar to those of Superman.
And for that reason,
he's generally considered the Superman of earth 26 for events that bring the
respective Superman from various universes together.
Now we have superhuman strength, endurance, and durability,
as well as superhuman hearing and sight. And now instead of being able to fly,
however, captain carrot has the ability to jump really far.
The one caveat to captain carrots powers is that his power supply must be
replenished periodically by consuming cosmic carrots Bruin in the soil that was
struck by the radioactive meteorite fragment. Now,
if counting carrot goes 24 hours without eating another carrot,
he reverts back to his normal power level,
which is that of a near-sighted human rabbit hybrid that draws comic books.
Luckily for him,
he's managed to produce a near constant supply of cosmic carrots by dedicating
part of the zoo crew headquarters to growing them. And so with all that in mind,
it's time for us to declare a winner.
And this is probably the most ridiculous battle that I think we've ever done
more so than. I think we're going to put this on YouTube proper
because both these characters exist in universes where the laws of physics are
not applicable and the multi versus,
and the book captain carrot even points out that the laws of physics are
different on earth, 26 than other earth.
And so we thought Perpetua would not be able to cause as much destruction there.
And the reason this makes things difficult is that it's just hard to get a sense
of how powerful these characters are. Because more often than not,
they're doing things that are absolutely absurd,
but you guys knew that when you picked it and it's actually probably why you
picked it.
So let's just move on to figuring out who would win between captain carrot and
spider ham. I love captain carrot guys. I'm sorry. I love captain carrot.
He's amazing. He's so awesome.
I feel like we should cover captain carrot and his amazing zoo crew.
I feel like we should cover those comics. They're so fun. They are so much fun.
But leaving aside that he's an anthropomorphic pig,
spider ham is for all intents and purposes. Just another version of Spider-Man.
He has all the same powers of Spider-Man.
He has a scientific knowledge of Spider-Man and he's a newspaper photographer.
Just like Spider-Man really, the only difference is that he's a pig.
I guess he theoretically does have pig powers in addition to a spider powers.
And his heightened sense of smell is likely due to that,
but I'm not sure what other powers he would get by virtue of being a pig captain
carrot. On the other hand,
although cartoonish in nature is still a Superman analog.
He's the strongest hero from earth 26 and has been called upon on more than one
occasion to fight alongside the other Superman from the multi-verse as such his
powers are on an entirely different level than spider Ham's justice.
Superman's powers are far beyond those of Spiderman.
So nine times out of 10 captain carrot emerges victorious here.
The one out of 10 shot that I would give spider ham is if he's able to prolong
the battle longer than 24 hours and figure out a way to keep counting care from
replenishing his powers by eating another carrot. Now,
although this is unlikely due to the advanced carrot growing operation,
captain carrot has set up,
which has been investigated multiple times by the DEA. Uh, no, it hasn't.
I don't know why I said that probably because growing carrots in order to get
power, sounds like something, uh, uh, like a, like a meth head would do,
but spider ham is a highly intelligent pig.
So maybe he can figure out a way to do it,
or maybe he can come up with some advanced technology to negate the radioactive
effects of the soil and thereby deprive the carrots, other special abilities.
I just want to say, I think it's hilarious to let,
like the idea of meeting a meth head who's like cultivating or like,
like cooking and like some room somewhere. And they're like, what are you doing?
It's like, I'm making my cosmic Herricks man. So I can become captain carrot.
I mean, it's, it's not good, but I feel like it's hilarious.
Or like somebody growing in like their basement. And they're just saying like,
they're their cosmic carrots, right? Like, I feel like that'd be hilarious.
I don't know. It just sounds funny to me,
but regardless barring the ability to prevent captain carrot from being able to
consume one of his carrots within a 24 hour period,
captain is going to win almost every single time. What would that be? He said,
guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you guys are new here to come and to explain,
make sure you guys have the sub button become part of the Rob port.
If you guys want to see more versus videos,
go check out the Patrion where you guys get to vote on new videos every week.
And I will catch you all later.
Priests
[inaudible].